all I know is that it's
[Music]
is mr. jingles in heaven will Brooke at
her revenge and where the is birdie all
this and more tonight in our episode 8
breakdown yes we are on our final two
episodes of American Horror Story and
things seem to be falling in place for
one of the most epic massacres of all
time so let's get right into the story
as we take a deep dive into the episode
we are one day before Halloween 1989
which means one day before the giant
camp redwood festival Brooke and Donna
are at a diner having left crazed
hitchhiker serial killer Bruce thumbless
on the side of the road it's kind of
ironic you know that the hitchhiker
killer gets his thumbs chopped off I
like it they are still on their mission
of revenge to hunt down Margaret for
being the mastermind behind both the
1970 and 1984 camp redwood massacres
there's a great Crocodile Dundee
reference that's a knife when Donna
tells Brooke she's a final girl if you
want to know a little bit more about
what a final girl is I talked about it
in more detail in my episode 8 preview
video they're interrupted by a National
Enquirer reporter by the name of Stacy
Phillips and if there's one thing we
know about The Inquirer is that they'll
stop at nothing for the truth she's
written books on killers such as Bundy
and Dean and is now working on a new
story about the massacres committed at
redwood by jingles and Brooke for her
they can't personifies everything wrong
with the 80s they excuse themselves with
Brooke thinking they've been discovered
she can't recognize your dead as we all
know the world thinks Brooke is dead
after Donna was able to fake her
execution via lethal injection back at
Camp redwood were with the hitch-hiker
still caught in his never-ending death
cycle imagine being stuck forever with a
puka-shell necklace
mister no thumbs approaches in a sweet
new ride and you know kids always get in
the car of a man wearing bloody bandages
Bruce is also on his way to Redwood
seeking revenge from Brooke and Donna
who tied him up and left him for dead he
also has an obsession with increasing
his kill count which will come into play
later on picking up the hitchhiker we
hear the muffled yells of someone in his
trunk these belong to a Mary Kay
salesman Mary
okay being a popular brand of cosmetics
she was the one who saved Bruce but he
just ended up stabbing her and stealing
her car using the cigarette lighter to
cauterize his thumbs
my best guess here is that the stabbing
occurred while in the Redwood property
and that shall return as a ghost for the
big massacre to come next episode there
is also a hint that Bruce has a split
personality when he opens the trunk to
tell Mary Kay to shut up mind you this
is before he picks up the hitchhiker
notice no one in the passenger seat he
tells her we're trying to listen to
Creedence in the subtitles and IMDB
Dillon McDermott's character is named
Alex but he introduces himself to Brooke
and Donna in Episode seven as Bruce so
it's possible these are the names of his
dual personality Margaret and Courtney
observed the aftermath of Ricky's
kajagoogoo slaughter with Ricky leaving
his trademark pentagram and blood on the
roof
Courtney is given the worst assistant
job ever having to cut up all the
members of the band dispose of their
bodies and clean up the bus before the
big show
with so many people getting cut apart
this episode it's no wonder why it's
called rest in pieces while taking a
garbage bag of goo out he finds the band
rehearsing they too will be ready for
the massacre I haven't seen this many
ghosts inside dated on tinder Ricky
stops a Billy Idol roadie who shows him
Billy's silver jewelry
now Billy better be showing up next
episode or this whole scene will be
completely pointless because although
fun it really doesn't give us any new
information in our next scene Ricky air
guitars - Billy Idol's rebel yell which
was released in 1983 and was ranked
number 79 on vh1's top 100 hard rock
songs of all time
out of the blue jingles attacks who has
sworn to kill Ricky to protect his son
and avenge his wife Ricky sees things
differently telling jingles that he did
him a favor jingles had lost his way and
this was to steer him back on track
Ricky is also pissed at jingles for
essentially turning him in he'll later
tell Bruce that jingles was responsible
for offsetting the years of killing he
had ahead of him remember it was jingles
who pointed out Ricky that ended up with
his arrest their fight is cut short
however when Bruce slams into jingles
killing him
but Bruce is more interested in Ricky
one of his idols even calling him an
inspiration Bruce wants the opportunity
to work with a legend and asked if he
can help track jingles something Ricky
will take him up on after they use his
satanic powers to track jingles down now
I really hope there's some sort of
Apocalypse tie-in here we've gone
through all these episodes and Ricky's
relationship with Satan hasn't really
been explored it's just like he has his
power and it's never really talked about
back at the motel Stacey knocks on
Brooke and Donna's room telling them she
knows who they really are
she's been studying redwood for years
and even paid the warden $1500 to get
the VHS of Donna at Brookes execution
that's like the amount of money I'd pay
for Xavier sex tape instead of turning
them in Stacey agrees to let them go if
they can provide her with a better story
and Brooke and Donna agree Stacy will
drive them into redwood and in return
they'll show her the locations where all
the murders happen as well as try to
prove that Margaret was behind it all
jingles resurrects telling the
hitchhiker that he felt at all but the
scariest thing that hitchhiker mentions
is that every time you die it's as if
pieces of you go missing and that's the
last thing jingles wants he can't forget
why he's here in the first place his son
he needs to kill Ramirez and end it all
for good Trevor has hooked up with
Montana with the VIP cabin experience
remember if you pay some extra cash you
can stay in the actual cabins where the
massacres occurred very romantic Montana
reiterates her plan to Massacre everyone
at the festival in order to draw
paranormal investigators who may be able
to help her from this purgatory she
wants anything but to be stuck at
redwood forever trevor is in love with
her and as we'll find out later we'll do
anything to be with her I love you
Montana
you're a tease forever Margaret watches
Trevor kissing Montana from afar
remember they are married and she's
gonna be pissed my guess is that Trevor
will die next episode and it will be
Margaret who does the deed the bromance
between Ricky and Bruce intensifies as
they continue their hunt for jingles
when Xavier offers to help after all it
was jingles who put him in that oven in
Episode four he takes them to his body
when jingles attacks and kills Xavier
you stay you die hey i'ma head out
jingles tells Ricky he killed himself
but since jingles can no longer leave
Redwood Ricky threatens to go to Alaska
and kill his son Bobby as a final act of
revenge this Tilt's jingles who is then
shot by Margaret needing the help of
both Ricky and Bruce for her final plan
Brooke and Donna takes Stacy where
Brooke was strung up in episode four but
she ain't buying the story for her
though it doesn't matter telling a story
that sells does Brooke is about to kill
Stacy when she's stopped by Donna but
she says if she went through with it she
become just like Margaret and jingles
there's evil inside you yes it sent us
off it grows in us like a cancer only if
you feel it once jingles and Margaret
became killers because they fed their
hate and anger if they can get revenge
without hurting another innocent soul in
a wash away everything we ever did
Stacy runs into Ricky Margaret and Bruce
but already knows too much and is killed
Margaret divulges her plan that she
wants to do something that has purpose
remember she owns and has profited off
of properties once owned by serial
killers creating bed-and-breakfast 'as
for thrill-seekers and haunted house
enthusiasts to visit if they can kill
all these famous bands it will attract
hundreds of their fans to pay homage and
stay at camp redwood making her a
fortune as long as Billy Idol isn't
killed Trevor says he wants to kill
himself to spend eternity with Montana
but she ain't about that she's down and
out because she was outed for bringing
Ricky to the camp she also exposes the
double standard of men's serial killers
being revered while women always get
blamed for making them that way why are
we always the scapegoat for sick men to
blame their [ __ ] on
she says she's irredeemable but Trevor
tells her she can change Montana lets
him go
I mean come on mr. Shue is in love with
you and he has an elephant trunk you're
a psycho now this is the scene I really
want to talk about there are a ton of
unanswered questions here and I want to
hear what you guys think in the comments
below but I'm gonna lay out all the
facts and theories so you can decide for
yourself what's really happening it
starts with Xavier and the two
pranksters stabbing jingles by the dock
and setting the rowboat out into the
middle of the lake so he can bleed out
and die the same lake where his younger
brother died years ago
this really sucks for jingles because if
he dies that's just more time he's
wasting when he could be out searching
for Ricky so he doesn't end up killing
his son now there's nothing really out
of the ordinary here with the boys
telling jingles he'll die a slow death
than just resurrect again as normal but
I want you to pay attention to some key
lines of dialogue like one of the
pranksters saying what someone does help
him and he does achieve peace as he
apologizes to Bobby in a rowboat he sees
Montana by the water
now she's either here for one of two
reasons one because this scene is an
homage to Friday the 13th sending and
she's here to act as a stand-in for the
police in that version or two and this
is more conspiracy theory if Montana was
there and saw jingles being taken away
by Bobby will it provide some sort of
key to how the ghosts can get out if
jingles like some argue makes it to
heaven at the end of this episode does
the lake and/or Bobby provide some clue
as if some sort of portal to the other
side jingles awakens with young Bobby in
front of him and is taken to Lavinia
remember she's been searching for Bobby
for decades and only now has finally
found him all the clues point to this
not being camp redwood even though you
can make it one of the cabins in the
background
the first thing jingles asks is where he
is which for a guy who has spent years
at redwood should be able to know every
inch of that place but again he could
just be foggy since memory loss seems to
be a side effect from resurrecting the
second clue is Lavinia is demeanor
she's all of a sudden kind and forgiving
to her jingles has made some sort of
quote ultimate sacrifice which has
somehow brought back
Bobby he's with us again you brought him
back to me
Lavinia tells them they're a family here
and this is where he can find peace but
remember what that prankster said you're
never gonna find peace not while you're
here jingles is then posed with a
question from his brother to stay with
them if they're already dead at camp
bread wood this is an odd question since
he'd have no choice but to stay with
them Bobby even says to jingles that if
he stays no one would be able to hurt
him here is that because he has powers
or is it because they are someplace
different than where the others are also
there's this whole question if Bobby was
at the center of the curse does that
mean that curse is now over and the
episode ends with jingles playing with
Bobby and the Ducks the ending mixed
with the music really feeling like this
is the end of jingles story that he has
redeemed himself and ended up with his
family in some sort of heaven his soul
finally at rest so will we see jingles
again I can't help but think yes even
though in the preview video he's not
shown at all if this is indeed a way to
the afterlife it should provide a clue
for how the campers can get out and
jingles might be that link between the
two worlds I posed this question on the
HS subreddit and user verdigris speech
had an interesting theory that the lake
could act as some sort of portal meaning
jingles could go back and warn the
others to avert the massacre saving all
the 80s bands we know and love there are
so many different ways this could go
from here and I want to hear your
theories and comments below I'll be
coming out with a preview video which
has a ton of juicy details in it for the
next episode so make sure you're
subscribe and stab that like button
while you're at it you can also follow
me on twitter Epting story YT until next
time remember daddy loves you very much